the legend goes you got very good by
training mostly with lower ranks uh what
was your training like in that
environment
so when I first moved to London I was 20
years old
I opened my school there
and I had nobody to train with
I had one guy that was teaching with me
a black belt middleweight
it was good
and that's it brother was May he moved
to the same this he moved to England the
same time as I did but he was in
Birmingham so we did got together you
know maybe twice a week closer you know
when we were prepared for something
if not then not very often as often as
we could but did I say not that often
and I had just
call about students there was no one
high level there was no one world
champion in any belt to train
then you need to create a scenario that
simulates that can simulate
you know like a realistic
fighting so I think on that aspect you
know when people
said you know people ask
why they have such a basic game I think
that also influenced me sharpening up
all my skills when I move there because
you know when I'm when if you practice
with people
you know lower level than you you cannot
there's nothing to to learn
from them or you know you can learn
things and practice with them but
outside
very complex scenes on them it is not
the best so it's
I sharpen up all my skills so I you know
that when I really improved everything
that I already knew to a higher level
but how can you sharpen something if the
resistance is much lower level then a
purple belt can makes it very hard for
you to skip side control doesn't have to
be a war Champion for black belt
it's you know if it's one is holding you
it can be very hard go to bar on the
attack how do you how do you become
literally by far the best person at the
cross truck from Mount by training with
purple belts
it's sometimes football belts defense
will be better than black belts okay see
a lot of people listening to that would
be like that makes no sense haja Gracie
how does that make any sense because
like a lot of the black belts even world
champion they get to the black belt
they're really good enough what in what
they do let's see in the guard you know
on on top on the bottom position but the
difference or not so I very very few
people high level have a very good
difference because they don't practice
yeah then that goes back to how you
train you know you can be very tough
very tough it'll make you terrible
defense because you're not going to
practice your weakness so your weakness
still gonna be terrible you can have the
best God in the world impossible to pass
the day people pass to God you do
nothing
like it's you your guard is high the
highest level but your side control
defense or not your mouth defense or not
so some purple Bells they practice this
you know the the amount way more than
that black belt did so the naturally the
difference is better so they they get to
experience the defensive position much
much more and especially training with
you they get really good at defending
and then over and over again you attack
them with the same thing over and over
again and didn't know what's coming they
will block they will develop a defense
over that yeah way better than most
other high-level blackboards so both put
yourself into really bad positions with
lower ranks and just keep attacking the
same way over and over and over
yeah
and with that you were able to be at the
top of the world at the World
Championships yeah
I mean can you give some like what was
the preparation like to a world
championship with the lower ranks I mean
um I did a lot of boxing a lot of
conditioning no but the conditioning is
but they won't seem to help me extremely
living in England in London was training
Judo at the Budokai in London that
helped me massively because he he gave
me the motivation to learn something new
because it you know that by then at the
Budokai you know the stand-up was I'm
sure today it is too but by them was
even higher than it is today like there
was some very high level Judo guys
training there and
I mean the first time I went there my
stand-up was terrible compared to theirs
I mean was was bad but compared to them
was terrible so I was getting through
like a child
and that motivated me to kept to keep
coming back and and and get better
so that made my Jujitsu much stronger I
became my base got better my top game
improved
my pressure game improved
did uh does Neil Adams train uh Ray
Stevens when he I've never met
neurologist
is that he's the voice of Judah I don't
know if you watched the tournaments he's
uh incredible yeah Freddie Stevens is a
you know Superman and silver medalists
in the Olympics he won European to me he
won a lot so he did some Judo training
what's your favorite throw like uh
if I would pick one so that made you
better at ggs as well yeah yeah okay and
and back then like for the first I'll
say maybe three years maybe four
I went to Brazil for like two months
before every major tournament yeah so I
said you know I moved away from the
school and I really focused I was really
well prepared with my jewelry and
everything else sharpen up my skus and
then went going to Brazil to train with
like really high level people
so that way I would manage it to compete
in the highest level